but the best achievement in  cinematography this year the nominees  are each on way for farewell my  concubine  Michael Chapman for the fugitive steward  dreiberg for the piano and Janusz  Kaminski for Schindler's List and the  Oscar winner and my new best friend is  Janusz Kaminski for Schindler's List  who being able to visually tell the  story of Schindler's List has been the  most important event of my professional  life I would like to thank Stephen for  that I would like to thank my father  that's for him I would like to thank the  fine international crew acting crew I'd  like to thank the fine international  crowd I like to thank the actors I'd  like to thank my gaffer the ambassador  and Malraux fiora Stevie Ray Allen  Starsky great producers Brown Kalu stick  and Jerry Mullin all my friends and  supporters thank you  next Tom Cruise joins us at a tribute to  one of Hollywood's most enduring actors  all Newman